yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is coverage of the first round of
this year's Tata Steel tournament are
bygones a played in wagons II and the
Netherlands yeah at least almost all of
the rounds of play they I think they
have the odds round that is not played
there but in Amsterdam or dead hawk I'm
not quite sure they have some some
special rounds that are not at the usual
venue anyway let's get going with round
one and they have to tell you right away
that this video is meant as a somewhat
light-hearted overview of the round I
was very busy today and will be tomorrow
so it's not a super deep analysis of
everything but I promise you that you
will have a pretty good idea after
watching the video what happened in this
round we have seven games in the a group
and this is quite a lot of ground to
cover so let's get going we'll have a
quick look at the not so interesting
games but so you will know afterwards
what happened we had ye the Chinese
prodigy here with white playing a
grandmaster thomashefsky from Russia I
think thomashefsky is the current
Russian champion if i'm not mistaken and
he's a absolute player to watch if you
an opening yeah geek nerd whatever you
may call it because thomashefsky is
believed to be one of the best prepared
players around so very interesting
always to see what he plays in the
opening yeah why iam almost exclusive
1.e4 player so we have a rural Lopez and
too much chef scheme place this mu order
signaling his intention to shoot for the
marshal attack after c3d fire and this
didn't happen in this game or ever sv
event for a for as most players do
nowadays and this they avoid the proper
marshal by going a 4 or d3 or h3 or one
of those n time
our minds here black has a couple of
moves um well mostly to Bishop d7 and B
form nowadays before has the best
reputation and it's played by
Tomashevsky my evo goes for d3 and the
move deform is more popular nowadays
even though after the six it seems that
black is okay they have been a couple of
games in this line in recent month for
example that was very nice win by
aronian with black / Nakamura in the
sink filled cup if i'm not mistaken um
d3r ever played by valve and now
Tomashevsky takes this opportunity to
put his bishop outside of the pawn chain
with Bishop c5 looks like a loss of
tempo but the bishop is nicely placed on
c5 and white setup is not especially
aggressive so it does make some sense of
course black also could have played and
moved like a cat d 6 or rookie a
something like that but that makes some
sense as we said d 683 age 63 or very
normal moves and after Bishop 87 we saw
Bishop e3 so we got some trades and and
in general it looks like black should be
fine here this position on also bear
some semblance to some lines in the
Italian game the only thing that is not
very Italian is that a four and A four
move and opponent before but other than
that it looks like a pretty tame version
of some Italian game black um will get
his Bishop to e6 and most likely trade
White's bishop or as it happened here Y
term will do it voluntarily Bishop to
Knight to be five Queen d2 Bishop d7
black has no bad piece and seems to be
okay yeah and now after night see form
Bishop to e6 93 Bishop to d7 not see for
bishop to its
93 Bishop to d7 they agreed to a draw
there is not a very exciting game we
have to say but I I understand in some
way how this result came about by years
completely new to those top tournaments
and didn't have a very good result in
the qatar masters just about three weeks
ago and what Tomashevsky is got black
against somewhat unpredictable player so
draw is not so bad couldn't they have
played on of course but it's not so easy
to be honest because in this position
the most 93 fields rather natural to be
honest what if we look like here we look
here right and what is why it's supposed
to play he would like to play deform but
this is not possible as the pawn or
deform is hanging and how do you ever
make some progress in this position it's
not so easy yeah you can of course you
can shuffle around but I think both
sides were pretty comfortable with that
draw so not so exciting this game let's
shoot for who you found with white again
Sega kayaking and a surprise right on
move one the best woman player she goes
for 93 out of one which is quite unusual
she is a almost exclusive 1.e4 player so
surprising to see her go for Knight f3
but maybe she had some specific idea for
kayaking you never you never know what
their what was the plan need to shuffle
my notes sorry for the possible noise
yeah 93 kayaking d5 g3 and g6 this is
slightly surprising to be honest kayak
eNOS very much sticking to his setups
and this is not one of his usual yeah
opening lines normally he goes for this
against night
3g three and maybe um yeah who you find
it something particularly prepared in
case of that she almost could expect
this kind of this kind of mousse and
maybe she had some idea was d3 we don't
know g6 playback hey I can cry yeah it's
it's a counter surprise in a way yeah no
she went c4 and ki can took this pawn
and black can also play d4 it's a bit
more ambitious but the capture is very
solid this has been played for example
in one of the first games maybe even the
first game of the World Championship
match between Carson and Donald in 2013
the first match um night a three Bishop
g7 94-96 Bishop g2 d5 this is one point
the setup of blacks opening line and to
probably honest I believe that black has
equalized see already that looks like a
very decent setup Black has got very
good control over d 4 and the position
is looking like some kind of reversed
dragon something that also could have
been reached via 1c4 1e5 um black as
good central control and it's very
difficult to give white a clear plan in
the game wyd tried a little bit
wondershare on the queenside here with
the night to a five and she tried this
yeah the thing is it is just very equal
after we should be six and b3 the
straight and now c5 why does gain white
is gaining a little bit of space but if
you look at this it's a very symmetrical
structure so not much happening yeah I
will pretty much fast-forward through
the rest of the game there wasn't a
single moment where
one side could have gotten something
something tangible it was just a very
correct game yeah why this a little bit
more comfortable maybe but there was
never clear danger to two blacks
position so a draw here which is not a
bad result I think for for both players
may be kayaking mean if you are like a
almost 100 point favorite you want to
try a little bit with black and yeah
this is Linus is solid he tried but who
you find it's not yeah I'm not going to
lose a pretty simple position like that
so it was a pretty fair result with that
draw and let's look at the world
champions game next council with black
is playing a David navara the top player
of the Czech Republic yeah we don't know
what opening to expect us nevarez play
upon everything we get a Queens gambit
and mangos has gone with night BTW 7
which is somewhat rare but not a not a
bad move one idea of the movies that
black quite often want some classical
type of Queens gambit structure while
avoiding this variation where um black
of course has decent equalizing chances
but it is not yeah a very attractive
prospect too many too many people and
that night bd7 move it some after Bishop
f4 didn't happen in the game but it's
leading to something entirely different
because here black can capture and after
you three for example you can defend
that porn for a moment okay white can
still play that due to Queenie fo check
but it just leads to different positions
um Navarre choose to transpose into the
Queens gambit declined exchange
variation the so-called card spot
structure
and the structure always had the
reputation of being somewhat better for
white a little bit at least and quite
often we had lion swam um things were a
little bit one-sided wear white was
pressing a little bit and black kind of
suffered in recent years however there
have been some kind of reassessments and
some new ideas have been found how black
can play and counsel is playing one of
those interesting ideas that to be
honest I wasn't aware of that much but
while we're looking at this game and
looking at it afterwards it was really
an apparent that there are a couple of
new ideas there whatever what am I
talking about here yeah he um in recent
years Oh wanna say differently like 20
years ago 30 years ago everybody would
play Bishop e7 and castles let's say or
they would have done that without age 6
the move h6 has a very clear idea see
now Carson did not want to play a
readily passive developing move every
cell no he went for g5 very interesting
and back night h5 and this is a very
interesting approach um Black is pretty
much securing himself the bishop pair by
capturing on g3 Bishop d3 is very
logical we can put that on the board to
see it more clearly black is getting the
bishop am and um gets to fianchetto his
Bishop on g7 not putting it on d6 or e7
the big drawback here is the weakening
of the f5 square and the light squares
if um which is I mean it would never
happen this kind of position but if
black would have at the porno g6 let's
say blacks position would be very very
comfortable here with the pair of
bishops no weaknesses whatsoever here he
suffers from that at five weakness is
weaker weaker square and with it also
the king is suffering a little bit
because black is definitely going to
Castle sure there's no
real alternative to that castles a 5 a 3
& castles Quincy to ya looking at that
square rookie 8 and be 4y displaying for
that well-known minority attack on the
queenside um attributes there is not
that much else that white can go for
here yeah in some other on Queens gambit
declined exchange variation type of
position you can also sometimes play on
the Kings sadia play put a night on e 5
player for all that is impossible with
black having the bishop on g7 the 997 so
why does pretty much reduce to the B
floor plan and he wants to go b5 and get
to weaken blacks structure on the
queenside the typical plan of the
minority attack cars no ever puts an end
to that immediately goes just be five
you know blocking or be five ideas yeah
and here um yeah navara is looking
forward to open up the queenside I'm
quite quickly it plays this attacking c6
covered and now the capture the reason
is why white is capturing and that in
some cases you have to be a yeah on the
lookout that black is not getting in
something like that's a a four-night
over to see for that could be quite
awkward so wyd wants to open the
position and get at those pawns so the
capture makes lots of sense rook takes
and night before attacking the big pond
and Carson covered it with twin to a
five a to a 8 i'm sorry chan the bishop
is going to f5 and the night pretty much
has to go to be 6 intending night see
for the thing that is kind of worrisome
for black is that there are not many
pieces around the king yeah the rook
here the Queen here
minor pieces hmm yeah this looks still
it looks kind of shaky however and
sometimes the the issue is that they're
the light squares might be weak but how
exactly do you get to black ski on the
light squares you only can come through
that color complex with white because
the dark squares are completely
controlled by black and sometimes you
have this kind of situation that it's
kind of weak on one square one one one
color complex but if nothing is
happening on that you are actually quite
safe and here it's not clear what white
is going to do navara went for this move
which is kind of logical not have seven
or threatened it pretty much forces
black to capture so that happened and
now the King fields really yeah really
hate asserted here 94 yeah counterplay
a380 5 and 23 now it looks dangerous e
six check however Carlton I guess has
everything under control he takes a
three so the queen is hanging so no no
you six check go in here and now black
has to yeah do something drastic yeah
you cannot play some slowish move now if
you let's say editing you capture here
then is secure check something like that
sees black getting wiped out now the
king is just far too weak but he has one
forced line that basically puts an end
to White's ambitious ambitions Sofia
festival the queen is attacked and there
is basically no choice what cannot
really captures Luke a1 Windsor rook so
this has to be done and now the Queen
gets taken white gets the Queen back and
like takes pawn takes aha it's equal
material but white structure looks a
little bit more healthy
the thing is that is not relevant
because concrete moves are in blacks not
favorites the wrong word but the
concrete moves let's say save the day
for black that night is attacked got
covered by the rook and now after 92
would be 294 there was this kind of
pendulum and a draw a very correct draw
I mean it doesn't look very exciting
that draw after 30 moves but I think it
was a pretty correct game cars have
tried an interesting opening idea with
that with a g5 approach it is really
interesting I mean we shouldn't be kind
of putting that mighty it's an
interesting idea to get some unbalanced
play out of a not very exciting opening
variation to begin with it's something
that can be useful for her players that
that idea because the Queens gambit
declined exchange variation is a problem
variation in many ways for black to
generate something in many mainline
Queens gambit declines there are
interesting sight lines and ideas where
black can try to complicate matters but
the exchange variation always is some
kind of loosens and those new ideas I
kind of welcome yeah even though it was
only a draw it still was interesting new
page and opening theory of that line
okay now let's go to the game in bizarro
with white against Luke friend Valley
yeah when many is some kind of a bit of
a dark was in that in that event is the
local guide the number two player of the
Netherlands behind anish giri but a huge
underdog rating wise compared to with
the other participants yeah let's see
what is doing against Mammadyarov with
black when really and by the way didn't
do that badly in recent term Vikings a
Tata Steel events especially with white
with what he was kind of okay again
most of the top guys but with Blackie
always suffered so it can be curious
what happens here I've got a slob
defense and momma Dee are of course for
g3 a line that was pretty much unknown
for yeah basically until this is the
right way to tell it until a couple of
years ago but especially due to the
efforts of vladimir kramnik nowadays
there are tons of lines where white is
playing some kind of g3 and just let
black take the sea for porn and just
yeah handle it like a Catalan yeah even
though there are some other things going
on that are not very Catalan like yeah
when really it's not the kind of person
to duck a challenge so it took that porn
however I have to have to say that I
believe that black has no particular
problems in my opinion if he just
develops with Bishop g4 for example I
don't see anything great then white has
in that in that kind of line something
like that see Bishop g2 night BTW seven
or six I think black has very good
equalizing chances there without any
adventure Sam anyway it was taken an end
card there so very principled play by
when really and just be three here by
Mahmoud young making it a pure pawn
sacrifice after this this white takes
with the pawn and it looks kind of
surprising that white can play just like
that where is the compensation for the
pawn yeah the compensation for the pawn
actually is very long term black
structure and we can put a couple of
more moves on the board they are very
logical i think is six covering c6
bishop here you know this seems i think
very very logical and group 28 yeah and
why it is a little bit
better developed as we see is almost
fully developed now the Queen maybe can
move but other than that all pieces are
in play and black still needs a little
bit of time the bishop is still on f8 he
has not cancelled yet and he's a little
bit behind in development however the
main compensation here is that it's
difficult for black to move any of his
Queen side pawns and in some situations
white might be able to get to pluck the
queenside end up in some kind of way
putting some peace on this e5 square
it's not easy for black to untangle
himself in this position now Mammadyarov
goes for a violent solution a direct one
pretty much typical of his direct
aggressive style however it might be a
questionable decision I think after a
slowish continuation like Quincy to for
example intending moves like let's say
Roxy one why definitely has long-term
compensation and here also the move d 50
Bishop c6 and then d5 gets a little bit
more yeah it gets gets to be more
interesting than then the game so maybe
black has to go 95 to stop any bishop
see sixes something like this for
example is a position where white has
compensation something like this and
this and why puts the night on c5 and
white has compensation with this more
more active pieces yeah this must play
Bishop c6 aha takes and d5 that was the
idea discovered attack the whole thing
is a pretty Force technical sequence
Bishop c5 why take this and black takes
only three aha so what is the point
white now has to take the rook this this
is check not helping at all take the
rook like recaptures and why takes here
yeah and here
we get to early on him to a very
critical position of the game here
Mammadyarov commits a mistake he plays
the move Knight takes b5 and this should
have lost the game actually what he
should have done is probably move
something like this Queen d3 some kind
of yeah not very direct move but move
that a text that Bishop force it is back
there may be like here and then white
can take on b5 or move one of the rooks
maybe like this what is the problem with
the with the moving the game night XP
five the problem is when really now
recaptured on b5 he already was in slide
time pressure if he captured with the
Queen he had a strong move forever
Knight to g4 then surprisingly would
have won the game I mean surprisingly
very early on and let's say and once you
look at it it's difficult to see why it
didn't choose it because the whole thing
looks so yeah dramatically bad for white
you know what cannot take the bishop if
we start with that after qui takes check
check the situation is hopeless for
white yeah we have this in the mix and
if the King goes up again hanks and we
have mating ideas why this just lost
taking the taking the bishop is
impossible I'm some other moves a little
bit tougher for example white can try
something like yeah it's in 93 that's
night f2m cannot call that tough Queenie
one you can play but this is also
entirely hopeless after Bishop Jake's
room jigs night takes and Queen takes
Queen B 5 so it's a bit mysterious
energy form would have wind pretty much
out right after when Venus move Queen
takes b5 why it could take only 30
could take he took on e3 and now this
position gets to be not that clear after
these moves why does rook and two pawns
even though those pawns well yeah let's
call it look at one point it against two
nights and I mean if anybody is better
is probably black but the worst is
definitely over um I don't want to go
into the rest of the game that much we
can head checked complications at the
end and check when really got that end
game with an extra night against two
pawns it's a kind of end game where you
well you would expect black twin somehow
but doing it is an entirely different
matter while looking through the game
had no particularly clear idea how that
would work yeah and also the engines
didn't didn't find anything either yeah
so it doesn't seem to be a very very
clear-cut affair we can look through it
a little better but yeah it's it was
really difficult to get rook and night
coordinated to win any of the thorns and
the way it went ultimately I'm not the
pawns even got God forward check check
and check check yeah like black was
trying of course but ultimately check
check and check so what's the wrong
button ultimately I think I'd lost one
of the pawns he should get the got the
age born running check yeah that got
lost but now the age time and was
starting to run and he got the e porn
and here the game was drawn yeah so a
bit of a disappointment for then really
could have had a great start to the
event with the wind with
black but he didn't see that Knight g4
resource that probably would have
decided the game in his favor maybe
there was something in the end game but
well I couldn't really see anything
neither did the engine so I figure it's
probably not it probably wasn't
something very yeah very obvious very
very clear nachi forever hmm it's a bit
bit strange that he didn't do that okay
um an hour can promise you some some
decisive games we still have three games
left and we have decisions in those
games um let's start with ding liron the
Chinese top player playing wide against
Micky Adams my notes there are semi
organized let's say put p.m. could be
better could be better okay and in this
game I want to look at some key moments
that say not look at the whole thing it
was a very long game clover 60-something
game moves but I want to look at a
couple of points um we had a an English
opening ac45 this is popular nowadays
many people even players who usually go
for sharper openings like ding they play
C for once in a while I think simply to
get onto paths that are not as trodden
as as others but it's not the way to put
much pressure on black either okay so we
had this English opening here all very
normal looking and now d for butting
very interesting I never saw that early
kind of D for in this in this opening um
and it seems a pretty decent idea first
impulses why not mine c4 isn't that a
week square well you can
go there but bit of an annoyance f6 has
to be played and then why just drops
back and here you can really ask
yourself was it worth it yeah tonight is
on c4 and looks kind of fishy on that
diagonal and f6 is kind of a very
useless move so this is not something
that black should go for he just too
pointy for I think solid and good
decision typical of atoms play c6 now
yeah and here Black's plan is to simply
get a full development with something
like Queen to e7 bishop CA tower droop
d8 yeah um very interesting play now by
ding I really like that idea played the
move a form not something that would
have come very naturally to me I have to
admit I probably would have thought more
move like 23 and rookie 1p piece based
approach but if was interesting why it's
ideas to simply push all the way through
to a six to weaken the queenside
structure and currently there is not
much that black can do about a five he
cannot move the a porn as any a porn
movies just blundering things so we went
Bishop f8y a very typical move going
back clearing the way and not having
this this Bishop sort of in the way I
think however that the move um Nazi for
maybe was interesting the night is not
great on b6 anyway and probably will get
some kind of kick by a five so maybe
moving involuntarily is an idea here at
least a five is not as dangerous yeah I
mean c5 is a good reply the bishop
doesn't have any good squares so I think
that was interesting actually to play
Knight to c4 the drawback of bishop f8
is that white gets that in the porn
pushes all the way to a six by the way I
don't think that black
in big danger here but what in some way
has gotten what you wanted and after 9p
to which is right Queen d2 94 I'm go
into f1 and Bishop t6 and green to see
one we get to a second critical position
here um black has to yeah somehow deal
with this Queen side pressure he played
the move Bishop b5 something that looks
very natural really very natural but it
seems to be a not sufficient form for a
fully equal position the move that the
engines suggest is very strange I have
to say it looks very strange and
probably wouldn't occur to many human
players it's a move Knight to e5 yeah
very weird move but the thing is that
it's difficult to get to tackle to
handle this for what you pretty much
have to take on b7 you know there are
also some ideas like that so taking on
b7 is very natural after black takes
yeah and now again there is this idea so
let's say Quincy to and black gets in c5
and all the Sun those pieces get raided
after something like Bishop e7 9 p-7
Bishop e3 and black is a pawn up which
is not mean his bad happen but he's a
pot up for the moment but has a weak
structure those pawns are both more
weakness and strength they are not like
strong passes and they are weaknesses
but I think black should always be able
to return one of the pawns and get to an
equal ish kind of position this looks
good once you see the line but Knight a5
is a really unnatural looking move so I
understand that it wasn't played there
should be five forever and seems to lead
to an advantage on the why
yeah for white community seven and TM
ding could have taken on b7 quite a
natural move actually Bishop takes a 94
and here black is in some trouble ideas
like 96 and queens 25 are very awkward
to meet I think here White has chances
for something quite substantially will
at least win the porn back with a with a
good position it's not quite clear what
what black some best shot is here
engines after while give Bishop c8 and
this is also not looking yeah like a
fantastic move it seems better this year
for what then what happened in the game
when ding played night you form um
before taking and now Adam some captured
on a six yeah it leads to similar ideas
f1 96-94 also was interesting and now
Queen c6 yeah around here why it was
better clearly Bella but um not really
better it was somewhat better but it got
it got to a somewhat more substantial
advantage later however step-by-step
animals managed to fight back into the
game and I want to not look at all
little chat details here and I want to
focus on one thing we see that why does
a pawn of him everything looks nice but
Adams was defending very tenacious Lee
and at one moment she had a chance to
actually draw the game we would see that
check yeah probably around here there's
a mistake by ding yeah it looks strong
yeah this attack but there is one
particular moment that is important here
that moves night to d8 that move is a
mistake here Adams could have drawn the
game with a very funny sequence of moves
you could have taken check
Jack very obvious and he saw that yeah
but the thing is after King f6 black has
a funny move night to see seven that's
really nice yeah putting the night on
pre but threatening rook is six mate hmm
what about that very nice so how is the
how is this continuing if white takes
them black has this funny reply rook to
e7 and now we see that if the night
moves then say here when Sun black is
you winning so the night cannot move the
best proof is to take it on g6 and after
Luke f7 King age five GG seven black
should hold the draw without any big
problems it looks a little bit tricky
with the three points but black should
draw pretty easily with the King helping
other alternatives after 97 well why
term we start with the with them with
some alternatives what else is there he
could have fun or here what can tribe
after where are we I am sorry here white
can try something else him he can try
this but Luke TX 95 black is always
ready to counter-attack this so why does
not just picking up two pawns and when
yeah we get the g3 porn yeah that was a
choice a chance to hold the game instead
of that 98 after 98 in the game like
here why does winning rookie seven check
here check and this maybe this was the
position that Adams was going for and he
overlooked that f5 now is the decider
this is the only move that winter but it
does win
because Black now has no decent move the
night is hanging and yeah well this is
not helping at all and what is else is
there he tried this chant after f6 group
28 white was a piece of and I'm still
tried this funny move threatening mate
and Stan late yep so that wasn't
possible but the winning move was fairly
easy just give this check with the rook
and after King takes and Knight takes
white has an endgame just a piece up and
Adams resigned after Luke a jade so we
had a had the chance to draw quite close
to the end of the game with this with
this rook takes III here and then this
funny moves 97 it was under pressure the
whole game and very often this is the
deciding factor you get to defend the
whole game you have to be precise and
then all of a sudden something yeah
something comes a long way you need to
be very precise and then you fail after
having solved many problems before okay
let's go to the next game this is kiwana
with ride against para el elyon of one
of the most successful players of 2015
alianore gained many points shooting 227
60 and the in the feed rating list yeah
okay we get a Queens gambit declined and
early enough tix on c4 which is usually
called the Vienna variation a sideline
of the Queens gambit declined but it's
an always some it's around yeah it's a
line that is played from time to time
bye bye strong players what is blacks
idea he grabs that point very often it
can get quite sharp and concrete in this
line there is basically no option for
white to to duck
challenge when you cannot play something
simple that still aims form slight edge
or something white has to play sharply
before this is the move Bishop before
and now Kara wanna goes for one of the
two principal main lines one is Bishop
g5 and the other is Bishop c4 taken and
castle so white has offered a full pawn
their only for a center born at that
this line was virtually unknown 10 years
ago let's say and then all of a sudden
people started to go for that and it
really seems that white has some quite
decent compensation for his central pawn
the normal line now the main line is the
capture and then black going back to e7
grabbing one c3 is really very dangerous
there should be seven and then white
goes 95 normally to have Queen g4 Bishop
h6 this kind of attack White's play is
based on it's very active pieces and
good development and it's a line that i
also have played myself a little bit in
blitz i never got it on the board in in
tournament chance and longer time
controls um it's not for everybody no
you have porn down here in the center
but against the Vienna some slow play
won't do um alien off now surprised his
opponent he played Knight f6 just going
back to have six this has been played of
course it's not a new move but in recent
years um was completely out of fashion
for example there was a game that was
pretty drastically lost by a parent with
black against aronian a couple of years
ago and black players didn't go for that
line recently um however it seems
interesting it doesn't seem obviously
bad or anything we'll see what what we
and what kind of position we get kawana
went Bishop g5 and if you look at the
clocks he took a long time so he was
surprised by the whole thing Queen a4
check was the choice in that mentioned
aronian um Ireland game this was
interesting however as well a koala did
he just he didn't do something um rash
yeah trying to get something for the
pawn immediately he just developed and I
think the next moves look very logical
in that regard black is going back there
develops night BTW 7 95 96 and puts the
night here that position yeah it looks
totally yeah it looks like an isolated
queen porn position on the white side
let's say but black has an additional
part to the c7 born normally there
wouldn't be a born on c7 and you would
say okay this is a normal position in a
way from a Queens gambit accepted or a
cara con pan or something like that
typical iqp position but black has a
complete porn food porn in addition and
what white has very free very active
development still it feels hard to
believe that this should be an
absolutely full compensation it really
feels hard to believe but if you see the
way the game unfolds it's how to give
black advice what you should have done
we'll see what happens Bishop d3 Bishop
to d7 94 yeah look how active White's
pieces are nights on e5 nights on d4
black has no way at the moment to make
his pawn count in some way yeah like use
it actively he just has to yeah have
heavy spawns back there passively they
cannot go forward and I don't really
know I think white has compensation for
the pod at first I was thinking hmm
really but it's so easy to play we are
I just piled up he gets all his pieces
on active positions and I can't Rupe to
the 1k for stopping any insight issues
and now H for ya White has a pretty um
pretty basic plan he wants to put the
porn on h5 Bishop back and give some
kind of main on each seven it looks
pretty primitive but it's very effective
and what is black doing you can always
ask yourself what exactly is that porn
on c7 doing well it's doing something at
the moment 96 covering this thing but
well why does playing on the King side
we just have white is just pushing
everything towards blacks King and what
exactly is black doing it's very tough
very tough to give black advice so why
does continuing with this build up
bishop has to be on the is to stay on
the board and now King age 8 here black
could have traded or someone and try it
for further trades um I think that was a
pretty decent idea to be honest just
trade things white however he has to
move Knight f6 and this leads to a draw
after black takes it Chanti want to
avoid that maybe maybe it's possible I
mean here this is a draw by by
repetition not sure if that was really a
rationale behind not taking on the one
and it's not clear by the way that the
move that you played King age eight is
bad not absolutely not it's just that
the drug trade is looking quite quite
logical interesting move now by Caruana
Bishop f4 it's a very simple plan Bishop
2d to take that night get the Queen on
the b1 h7 diagonal and go for that
checkmate on edge seven this is actually
what happens in the game room
Bishop d to root d5 takes takes takes 93
and we see that this is coming I don't
know did black did it black commit any
kind of obvious mistakes I didn't see it
if you give it to a computer by the way
it is giving about equal play equal
position but to play it over the board
is something else entirely because black
is always on the defending side it's not
so easy to defend all the time now and
this is the critical position there are
a couple of moves to play until move 40
and on a lien office down to five
minutes feeling the pressure he now
probably should play Queen to e6
stopping the e porn from moving forward
the movie played b6 seems to lose the
game it's just like that he really only
I think committed committed this one um
as it turns out substantial mistake
other than that there is no obvious
mistake on the black side now white can
win and check p is doing it ecigs check
is very strong Bishop f6 the move rook
to g7 is answered by the very powerful
short e takes f7 white can actually hang
sacrifice that rook he is threatening to
promote with f8 Queen so Queenie seven
and no funny enough why does sound
continuing with the very cool
continuation age takes 26 why does a
rook down but he's got this lineup black
cannot defend against this even 26 which
pins that can be answered very cool
there was kicking g1 and still those
moves are decisive quite quite
remarkable really this is the more
natural move anyway and was played but
it's funny how how bad i mean how
clearly Luke g7 can be refuted yeah now
Queen to f4 threatening Queen takes h6
check made now and well like only has
two moose the one that he plays loses
pretty quickly g5 but Bishop to g5 which
is better and probably also wouldn't
have been enough to save the game after
Queen takes f7 except it should be eight
Queen takes Bishop takes and takes on g6
um why this also clearly better yeah if
black takes the g6 pawn then this is
going to ups okay not the greatest arrow
but yeah you get the get the idea that
you porn will promote here yeah this was
a leonov's choice I had now queen air
five checkmate so threat to room 27 only
move and now just back and Knight a5 is
the decisive threat a plus this this
Bishop is hanging you went Queen
survived and now on to the capture night
f5 rook here and it takes f7 um alien of
resigned after look f8 this route 26 and
it's a fork on the two bishops yeah
quite an interesting game yeah in the
opening it felt like yeah it felt a
little bit like is that really enough
for what but we have seen how powerful
active pieces can be he was just
centralizing getting active active
powerful pieces it seems that Kara wanna
got a decent position for his pawn and
with all those threats piling up with
little time alien of didn't manage to
defend so Goodwin here for kawana in the
first round of talents deal okay one
game left and this is Wesley so against
arnesh Giri let's have a look there
again once before yeah we only had one
efore this game but a couple of c-4 sg6
buggery 93 and c5 an unusual move order
leading to a very closed position out of
the symmetrical English yeah a three by
Wesley so the idea is to play rook b1
and before yeah in this position only
many black players actually prefer not
to play a six and i'm not quite sure why
at least in games where you don't
necessarily feel like you want to win on
all accounts a six is pretty solid and
we got this be one group we ate before
and so on this is a very equal actually
but okay these six is of course not a
bad move I'm just saying I'm surprised
how often black players avoid that I
mean I'm not surprised if you want to
win with blacker than a six is the worst
try ever but i'm not sure that giri
really was like all out for for wind so
anyway group b 1 and now give we went
for a five this is not a move I like
particularly I have the same it feels
like on white as a comp has accomplished
something with provoking that weakness
and I'm not saying that it is terribly
bad it's just that I wouldn't like to to
play this kind of news okay d 3 e 5 here
for the so-called brought Vinick set up
with C 585 how
in combination with a 5 we see that
black has weakened disposition quite a
bit those two squares they look weak but
he has a very firm grip over the default
square in return 95 very unusual move
and very very early unusual move yeah
gimme played this now relatively quickly
um surprising in my book but okay I
would have expected maybe some kind of
yeah age six or so but may be done
before this maybe this was the idea to
get this in very very quickly okay
anyway night c2e cell and Wesley just
went back to see 3 yeah this is probably
right and back to c6 so those moves
didn't change anything here did they
make a draw no of course not and still a
surprising move was played I would have
expected an idea three in this position
and let's say 97 that's a castles
castles and 91 this kind of thing where
white is trying to play this regrouping
but this was chosen yeah completely
blocking the center with you for it
would seem that this should be equal
because I mean it looks completely
symmetrical the only thing is that well
there is a slight weakness but still it
doesn't feel very threatening let's look
um a couple of moves there should be
seven bishop t2 everything kind of
normal age six and now night be five
yeah and the thing is what is black
doing now the six is hanging you don't
want to play 28 let's say something I
could be eight
what are you doing the plate bit should
be six but now after night ec3 a 93 be
695 that is not looking very comfortable
that night is very annoying and they are
possible jumps to c7 and well you don't
want to take the night which is actually
what give you did at the end but it it
feels uncomfortable maybe maybe you
should have tried night to a seven try
to get rid of the be five nights at
least some lines then might be equal
maybe if white takes for example and
goes before this seems to be kind of
okay after Teague's own and takes and
takes six percent e7 and without nights
I think that must be about equal maybe
nine eight seven was an idea after this
left was playing in the game why it
seems to be quite a bit better quite a
bit better still quite surprising that
there are problems to solve that that
kind of weakening of the be five squared
it didn't look like so important but
white has has a little something Black
has to be cautious so this happened
night 87 and now 93 very important not
trading stuff keeping the night on the
board and making this night on a seven
look bad at five striving for some kind
of activity but now a very strong move
age form bias is strong it makes sure
that the white Bishop will come to h3
and this is a very strong square because
it gets black into a situation where he
does not want to move the f porn ever
because whenever you go work at four
hockey or taking then the bishop gets
you to scope and this way the black king
side play is in some way stopped in its
track
and well white his ideas and he's going
to play before and open up the queenside
so black wants to get some kind of play
on the King side this is the thing if
you are not doing anything then you will
probably yeah get-get crush on the crew
inside and give we didn't want to sit
around and wait he played the move f
form it might not be great to be honest
but I understand the idea if you sit
tight and wait for proceedings you're
probably going to get killed so I
understand it but the position is not
good Bishop a dream be five an hour yeah
so silent interesting night to a 92 and
looking at the f4 porn and black pushed
it I think after that it might be over
in a higher sense but the position is
not right anyway if you take here for
example chat check and whiter and
recaptures widest also better long-term
his his bishops are stronger he has
ideas on the queenside and black ass
under pressure but it probably was
better than have three the night goes to
see one and now very funny regrouping
night be three attacking the porn a
four-night a one yeah it looks pretty a
pretty weird but the idea is simply
night here here oh sorry e 1 and f 3
that porn seems to drop and if that porn
drops the game is over yeah nothing that
black can do if you play something
slowish that regrouping is coming he
tried before just stirring up trouble
but white can just take stuff here's the
first porn and a couple of moves later
the second porn was dropping and game
continued for a little bit but that
desperate Bishop takes h4 wasn't helping
youtube on rook c7 the IROC c7 the Queen
moves Queen B 7 is coming with the
checkmate threat yeah a very convincing
win at the anti by Wesley so out of a
very modest looking opening I'm still
kind of surprised how bad blacks
position all of a sudden got out of this
it doesn't look very dangerous area it's
completely symmetrical it's just this
slide weakening of b5 but the way it it
turned out I mean if we look at this
here black is under pressure maybe there
was some improvement before words I had
no very clear idea what L said well I
mean I already said that I didn't like
the decision to go in five but this in
itself is certainly not the cause for
the defeat but probably the move Bishop
takes d5 in higher sense night a seven
or well some other move let's say here
Bishop takes d5 seems to lead to a
structure piece distribution regards to
the pawn structure that is too difficult
for black to handle so after the first
round we have three players leading the
event with the victory ding Liren
fabiano caruana and wesley soul and a
couple of people with the drawers
Alienor fury and adam started with the
loss a very interesting few by the way i
really like it that they have a couple
of players in the event that are not
playing in all of the super tournaments
like alien off like navara also been
very right I mean he's providing
interesting games it doesn't have to be
the 2780 guys all the
it doesn't hurt to have the odd yeah the
odd rare guest let's say in an event
like that I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of round one the video as usual
got longer than I wanted but anyway hope
it was enjoyable thanks for watching